my name is Ashley and today I am going
to test out some of the most pinned
Halloween costumes from Pinterest every
year Pinterest rounds up their most
viral pins of the Halloween season I
picked three of those viral costumes I'm
gonna see if they're actually cute or
funny or any of the things that
Halloween costumes are supposed to be
out of all three of these one of them
better work because I need a Halloween
costume by next week
the first costume that I'm gonna make
today is a jellyfish costume I did not
know that jellyfish were so trendy right
now but apparently they are because not
only is this particular pin very popular
but as I looked into it there are like a
thousand other versions which I find
very interesting the first thing that
I'm gonna do is sew the scarves onto the
elastic band of the to tube her scarves
were definitely cooler than mine but I
could not find those anywhere the
thought of having to do like individual
little stitches to attach these lights
to this tutu kind of makes me want to
die so instead I'm gonna try hot gluing
it oh I think this will work
I'm trying not to glue it in like a
straight line around I'm trying to make
it a little more constellation s I think
I accidentally glued this to the table
Oh No well the last step is to put on
some pearls oh this is not easy I think
I'm gonna have to call in for backup and
buy backup I mean hot glue that's cute
I don't know if it looks like jellyfish
but it's cute I think this costume needs
a little bit of context like maybe it
could be a group costume and you're all
little sea creatures it takes a little
explaining to do but you know what
that's just a conversation starter it's
like no I'm not a Nimbus cloud thank you
for asking I am a jellyfish I'd say this
is for sure pinnable this next costume
is a little more complex it is a jetpack
that looks like it's supposed to
actually be lifting off the ground the
first thing I'm going to do is take a
bunch of colored felt and cut out pieces
of fire I have many flames here and now
I'm basically gonna hot glue them onto
these pants and make myself some fiery
legs so this could either go fiery
jetpack or very festive chicken the blog
that has inspired this costume said to
use cement
ding tubes I could not find that in
Manhattan anywhere so instead I got
these hamster play tubes they're like
meant for your hamster to run through
and chew up but we're gonna use them to
make a jet pack
[Music]
this costume requires not one but two
pairs of pants with the second pair I'm
going to basically fill them with
newspapers so we can have like fake legs
and then I'm gonna glue a light cheap
pair of shoes to the ankles this has
actually written all over it this is
hilarious like come on I think this
thing is gonna fall apart in probably
four minutes but for the five minutes I
did wear it this is pretty amazing I
wish I had a few more flames it's a
little patchy for the record I got 20
sheets of each color felt so I have 40
sheets itself all together you know is
it a sexy Halloween costume no is it an
epic Halloween costume hell yeah our
last costume is actually not a full
costume outfit it's a makeup look
basically what she's doing is putting
the dark shades where you would contour
and the light shades where you would
highlight I know a lot of you who watch
this channel or very good at makeup I am
not so bear with me as I try and figure
this out now I'm going in with one
that's just a hair lighter and I'm doing
those basically staggered on top of my
first round now I'm gonna do the lighter
shades where I would typically put
highlight so I've kind of got the
contour I've got the highlight and now
I'm gonna blend not blend I'm not gonna
use a blending brush on this absolutely
not that would defeat the entire purpose
of this but we are gonna blend by just
putting a medium shade in between the
dark and the light they're a little
messy and it's not really bothering me
that much I think altogether it sort of
gives the same effect but it is hard to
try and make them all the same size I'm
gonna move on to the eyebrows now I just
got a drugstore eyebrow pencil and I'm
gonna just make little boxes going up
and then one going down one going up and
then one going down before I was like oh
I'm gonna look cute now I'm like I look
a little crazy but it's still looking
cool sort of like eyeliner where you
just like keep working it and it just
gets worse the more time you put into it
so we're gonna step away from the
eyebrow and move on to the lip big
mistake I made was using lip gloss
instead of lipstick I just figured the
gloss would be easier to paint on but I
should have just used
with lipstick so that is something I
would do different next time but
otherwise I wouldn't change anything
about this I think you came out really
cool I would say that this costume is
definitely pinnable I had a really good
time making all of these I think they're
all pinnable in their own ways
sure mine weren't Pinterest perfect but
nothing really is
[Music]